hello and welcome to this video playing
nastradamus nastradamus farted fadi
aight so we place the y at a boring
place a clip let's see what happens this
my setup is not the most critical
probably against this opening but I
never bothered to look at something
really critical why does usually am ok
even in those are less critical lines so
maybe goes back yeah he does go back c5
probably not hmm probably just keep the
tension
see just aiming for if I here hmm maybe
both both moves he'll make censored ok 5
there is no tech tech yeah based on the
unprotected bishop it's a bit of a shame
should be five ed for this trip c6 mmmm
doesn't quite work queen bee three
maybe just takes on default something
it's a bit strange
okay so if i take now here on why can I
not taken from the canna any other good
square and all but this is a good square
I think so i could take with the rook or
with the Queen but both make some sense
look protects the form so that can
actually take with the rook no should be
more or less a clean pond I don't really
see any any compensation here and then
threatening may not so much that takes 5
SB should be too so I'm not threatening
night xe5 at the moment
okay yeah so we just use the pawn down
here in the look double booked and queen
position the only thing I have to be
cautious about this something stupid
like rook h6 screen d 7 h three or so
let's done the only counterplay that he
has
now maybe it'll come to play
black resigned that's early it's pretty
bad very pretty bad and them it also
that the queen is completely tied down
the the roots down so we had this
opening I don't know I played this
without much theoretical knowledge
taking on these six me i was expecting
the Queen to take actually okay can
certainly play that as well cave like
this played all the natural moves and
now he's high if you have a queen bee
three is just a double attack so it turn
it it takes f7 and b7 and yeah he has to
give up something this is what he did
not take c5 home okay yeah it was
possible that's it's ultimately not that
bad you're taking on deform was more
interesting him I'm also porn up here
but this is not as clear no here we
basically busted and okay it's an early
resignation but it's really not fun to
play I mean probably has to move the
Queen somewhat somewhere every seven and
the engine suggests before I had
something like this just a good
strengthening movement the black is
sitting on the weaknesses and is upon
down i also have a very compact king
position so there's no no hope for some
counter player ok guys thanks for
watching